bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur
l'antenne de lcp et public sénat nous
sommes ensemble pour revoir en 45
minutes les temps forts de la semaine
politique et parlementaire avec vous
mickaël szames sg cutter bonjour michael
et le débat a donc été suspendue sur la
loi elle conneries le gouvernement à
engager la responsabilité sa
responsabilité sur le texte
le projet de loi donc été adopté en
première lecture après le rejet d'une
motion de censure déposée par la droite
rendez-vous maintenant au sénat
cette séquence politique et
parlementaire risque de laisser des
traces au sein même du parti socialiste
les divisions d'éclater au grand jour
autres fondeurs et député loyalistes
tandis qu'au dehors la colère ne faiblit
pas dans les rangs des opposants a fait
lourd et puis il y avait un texte moins
polémique née important les sénateurs
ont voté la prorogation de l'état
d'urgence qui s'appliquera donc au moins
pendant l'euro de football organisée en
france notre invité cette semaine pour
commenter toute cette actualité jean
marc germain bonjour bonjour député ps
des hauts-de-seine proche de martine
aubry donc pas forcément d'accord avec
ce que fait le gouvernement je vous
propose d'en parler évidemment dans un
instant vous avez vu le menu à beaucoup
de choses on va commencer cette semaine
par cette actualité
un parlementaire soupçonné d'agression
sexuelle denis baupin car il s'agit de
lui député écologiste soupçonné
d'agressions sexuelles de harcèlement
par ses propres collègues
tout est allé très vite puisqu'il a dû
démissionner de la vice-présidence de
l'assemblée nationale les explications
de françois molins
c'est le site internet mediapart et
france inter qui révèle le scandale
les journalistes ont recueilli les
témoignages de huit femmes dont 4 élus
écologistes qui auraient subi des actes
de harcèlement ou d'agression sexuelle
de la part de denis baupin l'une d'elles
explique avoir reçu pendant plusieurs
mois des sms très crue du député
écologiste
ça a duré plusieurs mois il y avait plus
de 150 sms de ce type là alors j'ai un
peu parlé avant et j'en ai parlé à plus
or personne mais comme on nous dit que
ça nous détruira et qu'en plus on
allumera le parti et puis que c'est un
mec formidable qui défend nucléaire et
que les intérêts du parti doivent passer
avant le reste eh ben on se tait au sein
du parti d'europe écologie les verts que
denis baupin a quitté le mois dernier la
nouvelle direction se dit écoeuré on
ressent un sentiment de honte c'est mon
cas le fait que dans notre parti et puis
l'avoir ce type d'agissement dont j'ai
aucune raison de douter de la véracité
et puis aussi un sentiment de
reconnaissance et de fierté vis-à-vis
des femmes qui ont eu le courage de dire
les choses puisque le seul remède par
rapport à ce type d'agissement en tout
cas la seule façon de les faire reculer
c'est de le dire le président de
l'assemblée nationale de son côté n'a
pas tardé à réagir
claude bartolone a reçu monsieur denis
baupin il lui a demandé de remettre sa
démission de ses fonctions de vice
président de l'assemblée nationale
denis baupin qui n'a répondu à aucun
média pour le moment a annoncé qu'il
quittait son poste de vice-président de
l'assemblée mais conteste les
accusations de harcèlement sexuel
il envisage de porter plainte pour
diffamation alors depuis deux niveaux
par un porté plainte
simplement quand vous apprenez cette
nouvelle lundi matin comment vous
réagissez
c'est quoi votre première impression moi
je suis abasourdi parce que on connaît
tous denis baupin et personne ne pouvait
imaginer ça vous le croisez dans les
colorants même la normale et en même
temps vous savez moi j'ai été surpris
aussi par l' affaire strauss kahn
en son temps et donc on sait que ces
harcèlements existent dans la société
moi aussi je salue le courage des femmes
qui l'ont dénoncé
mais je salue aussi la dignité
au fond de la façon dont cette affaire a
été gérée monsieur baupin a démissionné
de ses fonctions de l'assemblée
nationale la ville est résident or il
n'a pas quitté son poste de
vice-président l' affaire a été portée
devant la justice
sa femme sa conjointe emmanuelle cosse
s'est exprimé aussi à la fois en dessous
tu n'entends conjoint mais en demandant
que cette affaire soit réglée devant la
justice et donc je trouve qu'au fond
cette affaire a été traitée de manière
assez digne par les responsables
nommément dépasse sa démission en tant
que parlementaire non moi je souhaite
qu'ils puissent se expliqué se défendre
devant la justice et que nous en tant
que politique
d'abord que chacun en tire la leçon dire
bien sûr on a des femmes et des hommes
comme les autres et que ces affaires
elle existe dans le monde professionnel
et dans les vies privées de chacun mais
non on doit être exemplaire et ça ça
doit pas être toléré
encore moins peut-être dans la vie dans
la vie publique et puis après il faut
aussi penser au problème lui même et la
question elle-même que ça soulève
moi par exemple pour moi être socialiste
cette féministe donc je souhaite que ce
genre de comportement soit bannie de
notre si cela vous dit ça aujourd'hui ça
a été dit par le passé au sujet d'autres
affaires est ce que vous pensez que ça
peut être un déclic ou qu'il y aura
encore une autre affaire et que c'est un
éternel recommencement
on dit les choses et puis on a
l'impression que deux affaires se révèle
et que rien ne change
je pense que le fait pour ces femmes
d'avoir dit ces choses là et ensuite
faits seront établis ou pas on verra va
faire progresser effectivement le
respect de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
et c'est très important il ya quelque
chose a changé selon vous la lorien la
parole s'est libérée sur le plan
juridique je crois pas puisque nous
avons voté des lois en début de
quinquennat et qui permettent de
sanctionner le harcèlement sexuel de
manière très forte sur le plan des
comportements bien sûr il faut il faut
que ça progresse
ou c'est moi je pense que ce qui
permettra de faire vraiment évoluer les
choses c'est la parité totale à
l'assemblée nationale c'est la parité
totale dans le monde politique et moi je
plaide par exemple pour que les partis
politiques qui n'ont pas non seulement
autant de femmes et d'hommes candidate
mais autant de femmes et d'hommes est
lui quelque chose près parce qu'on ne
mesure pas le résultat des élections de
manière
très précise et bien aiguisé plus de
subventions publiques parce que je vous
assure
quand dans les grandes entreprises vous
avez des femmes qui rentre dans les
conseils d'administration ça fait
évoluer les choses et quand dans un
conseil municipal c'est déjà le cas et
maintenant les conseils généraux vous
avez autant de femmes que d'hommes et
bien ça fait vraiment évoluer le
comportement politique
alors je vous propose de nous rendre
mardi au sénat où a été voté la
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
deux mois supplémentaires le sénat a
validé la prolongation d'état d'urgence
pour la troisième fois
3 109 sénateurs ont voté l'objectif est
d'assurer la sécurité de la france
pendant l'euro de football et au tour de
france c'est à dire genre doit prendre
fin
théoriquement le 26 juillet deux jours
après l'arrivée de la grande boucle
jean marc germain députés et sénateurs
ont rédigé un texte commun sur cette loi
qui prolonge état d'urgence il ya
consensus qui n'est pas si fréquent
surtout ces derniers temps vous voterez
aussi ce texte en séance publique
c'est à dire la semaine prochaine oui
bien sûr et je voudrais saluer le
travail que mène bernard cazeneuve qui
est très difficile parce qu'il essaie
d'assurer au fond la liberté de
manifester on en parlera peut-être dans
votre journal de d'avoir des grands
événements footballistiques y compris
qui est des fans zones où les
supporteurs pourront se retrouver et en
même temps la fermeté et la sécurité
vous savez la facilité pour lui sera été
dire il n'y a pas de manifestation il ya
pas de fan zone etc
non il prend rien et qu'il est d'une
tranquille pour moi l'aller on a trouvé
un équilibre et booster son à trouver
cet équilibre c'est parce que derrière
il ya un homme qui porte sa en lui
comment assurer la sécurité et c'est un
ministre de l'intérieur très faire mais
en même temps comment assurer les
libertés et il est toujours à l'écouté
quand il ya des associations qui le
saisissent par exemple en disant
attention porte atteinte aux droits
fondamentaux il dit ballet pas ça d'un
revers de la majorité
il essaye de le corriger les livres
qu'ils incarnent la sécurité il incarne
l'articulation entre la sécurité la
liberté profondément
il ya quand même des manifestations vous
en parliez à l'instant des débordements
encore une fois depuis des semaines
vous entendez par exemple ceux à droite
mais pas que qui dit comment est ce
possible alors cornet en plein état
d'urgence
et c'est vrai qu'on est à droite comme
de se poser cette question mais parce
que si on interdisait de manifester dans
notre pays sur des questions aussi
fondamentales que les relations de
travail travail c'est ce qu'on a pour
vivre quand on le perd on perd quasiment
tous si on pouvait pas manifestés en dix
ans n'est pas d'accord pour cette loi
vous rendez compte de la victoire monde
aisheen manifestations et agit des
casseurs non mais vous avez les
manifestants et vous avez les cartes ils
sont d'ailleurs comme les forces de
l'ordre victimes des casseurs vous avez
vu hier qu'il ya des services d'ordre de
la cgt qui s'est fait taper dessus par
des casseurs et vous avez des casseurs
d'ailleurs dont l'effet est plus de
discréditer le mouvement que quoi que ce
soit donc ils sont là pour taper mais en
même temps est-ce que pour autant il
faut interdire je crois que les
décisions que prend bernard cazeneuve
décidé d'encadrer au mieux et des
efforts ont été faits des deux côtés il
ya eu des renforcements des forces de
l'ordre il ya eu des renforcements des
services d'ordre des des syndicats voilà
alors cette semaine vous savez ça a été
marqué par ce psychodrame autour de la
gauche le 49-3 on va y venir dans un
instant simplement je voulais vous
entendre sur les propositions venues de
la droite les propositions économiques
on en sait un petit peu plus
cette semaine alain juppé s'est dévoilée
voici le reportage de sophie nommant
couturier fait une sorte d'état des
lieux
il est le premier à avoir lancé un pavé
dans la mare en matière de proposition
libérale c'est françois fillon qui donne
le ton des jo en 2014
l'ex premier ministre présente alors un
projet de rupture revenant sur plusieurs
acquis sociaux 110 milliards d'euros
d'économies mais surtout la fin des 35
heures la retraite à 65 ans la
suppression de l'usf ou encore la
facilitation des licenciements
économiques
ses concurrents n'aurait pas osé mais
devant cette radicalité
il se décomplexe et lui emboîte le pas
alain juppé le favori des sondages
préconise à son tour 100 milliards
d'euros d'économies la fin des 35 heures
la retraite à 65 ans est lui aussi la
suppression de l' isf au coeur de son
projet économique la relance de la
compétitivité des entreprises par une
politique de l'offre
nicolas sarkozy et bruno le maire plaide
eux aussi pour un plan d'économies
drastique et proposent respectivement
100 milliards
euros pour l'un et 90 milliards d'euros
d'économies pour l'autre la retraite à
65 ans 64 pour nicolas sarkozy est
toujours la suppression de l isf mais
aussi l'alignement des régimes du privé
du public comme le souhaite également
les deux autres candidats ainsi que la
suppression des régimes spéciaux
et c'est sans compter la diminution du
nombre de fonctionnaires et la baisse
des prestations sociales dégressivité
des allocations chômage et création
d'une allocation sociale unique idée
partagée par les quatre favoris de la
primaire à droite alors à ceux qui
disent la fin du clivage droite gauche
vous avez la réponse est oui je crois
qu'elle est très clairement montré par
votre reportage on va parler du 49 3 mai
ou si je devais résumer dire une seule
raison pour laquelle j'ai pas voté la
motion de droite hier sexy elle avait
été votée il y aura eu dans un mois le
retour de la droite au pouvoir avec la
retraite alors ça dépend des candidats
mais 65 66 67 ans avec au moins trois
cent mille suppressions d'emplois
publics avec la suppression des 35
heures et ses excès comme par exemple la
suppression du bien sûr que non vous
savez notre pays souffrent d'inégalités
et les iguanes égalité les plus fortes
elles sont font pas par le mérite par la
création et moi j'admire les chefs
d'entreprises qui sont capables
d'inventer des nouveaux produits et à la
limite de gagner de l'argent autour de
ça ce qui va pas c'est que quand on est
et on est certain qu'ils aient des
millions et d'autres rien du tout donc
c'est la question des successions et
c'est la question des grandes fortunes
gala juppé a présenté son programme
séduit l'ennemie de la gauche
aujourd'hui goûter jus c'est pas très
différent les candidats entre les uns et
les autres on le fait depuis que l'euro
dans les sondages
oui on prendra le candidat que la
première de la droite choisira c'est pas
à nous de le faire mais ce qu'on voit
bien c'est que ça joue dans le dos en
tout cas ça serait la jupe et ça change
moi je parle pas de danger c'est la
démocratie avait compris le danger là
celui de vie de celui qu'elle plus de
chances de l'emporter à la primaire
d'abord et ensuite face à nous c'est
clairement alain juppé c'est lui qui a
la chance de pouvoir gagner même si
c'est oui parce qu'il a su construire un
rapport à l'opinion
à faire oublier ce qu'il avait fait
quand il était premier ministre et à ce
qu'on parle pas tellement de son
programme mais vous le faites et c'est
très bien vous propose de revenir au
sujet de cette semaine qui concerne au
premier chef une réunion mardi de la
dernière chance a eu lieu à matignon
mais l'histoire de compromis s'est vite
éloignés faute de majorité pour voter la
loi travail le gouvernement a donc
décidé d'utiliser l'article 49-3 sur la
loi travail une décision dénoncée à
droite comme à gauche françois molins le
conseil des ministres qui s'est réuni
sous la présidence du chef de l'état m'a
habilité engagé la responsabilité du
gouvernement
c'est donc le passage en force qu'a
choisi manuel valls une décision que le
premier ministre avait déjà prises le
matin même après une réunion de la
dernière chance à matignon avec les
frondeurs du ps où aucun compromis n'est
trouvé
si le 49-3 est devenu réalité disent les
députés fidèles au gouvernement
c'est à cause des opposants socialistes
je fais le constat qu'une minorité de
députés du groupe socialiste se
positionne comme s'il était majoritaire
mais en fait ils le sont par alliance
avec la droite pour des raisons qui sont
encore une fois des postures politiques
des collègues ont choisi une méthode
dure je la considère comme tel
dont acte la décision d'utiliser le 49-3
avant la fin des discussions
parlementaires est un déni de démocratie
pour les fondeurs saab en ai dit mais le
dit mais c'est l'élection de françois
mitterrand en 1981 chaussée un triste
symbole que aujourd'hui le gouvernement
soit obligé de recourir aux 49 3 /
un texte qui n'a pas la majorité ni même
de la majorité des députés socialistes
dans l'hémicycle
les débats ont été houleux et les
députés front de gauche sont venus
renforcer les rangs des opposants à la
loi
qui aurait pu imaginer qu'un
gouvernement se réclamant de la gauche
aux ainsi anéantir notre modèle social
fierté de notre pays manuel valls
on a profité pour rappeler combien ce
texte est nécessaire à ses yeux ce texte
qui est bon pour les entreprises qui est
bon pour les salariés qui créent de
nouveaux droits pour les salariés et
bien ma responsabilité et notre
responsabilité c'est d'avancer et de
faire en sorte que ce texte soit adopté
quant à la droite elle a déposé une
motion de censure pour faire tomber le
gouvernement à rendre compte plus les
recours aux 49 3 est ce que celui ci
pour vous était prévisible est ce que
c'était la conclusion logique de tout ce
qui s'est passé d'un stade arena et plus
aucune chance de compromis non se tenir
à profonde et il y avait une chance de
compromis moi je les mises sur la table
dans la réunion que nous avons eue avec
le premier ministre n'ont d'ailleurs sur
le coup le premier ministre n'a pas dit
non il a fait lui-même une proposition
et on s'est quittés comme ça sans
conclusion puis ensuite je crois qu'il a
passé un coup de fil au président de la
république et que le quart d'heure
démarche engagée
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas c'était
tardif cette réunion elle aurait dû
avoir lieu avant le dépôt du projet de
loi
ou juste après parce que vous savez la
démocratie en dehors de situations liées
à la défense nationale
c'est trouver des majorités de
construire des majorités et c'est le
rôle du premier ministre
car les entendais j'entendais le
rapporteur dix 10 ans et un certain
nombre de parlementaires qui bloque les
choses alors que la majorité du groupe
socialiste et pour d'abord il ya eu un
vote qui a eu lieu en fait il a eu lieu
dans la réunion des socialistes où il y
avait alors il y avait des absents je
dis pas que c'est le rapport de force au
sein du groupe et mais il y avait eu 84
voix pour donc au les seules voies que
rond sûrs au bout du bout ce projet si
on en arrive pas à voter à un moment
donné il reste encore la deuxième
lecture ce sera ses 84 voix
donc on voit bien que en démocratie ça
peut pas être 84 parlementaire ou même
plus je suis honnête avec vous si ça
avait été dans l'est
cycle il y aurait peut-être eu 200
personnes 220 mais y aurait pas eu 290
personnes et ça c'est pas possible moi
je suis pour la suppression de l'article
49 3 qui est une aberration de la vème
république et qui comptent qui conduit à
faire des fautes politiques parce que
qu'est ce qui se passe aujourd hui
méritée du touât au temps où ben oui
mais bien de politique si on comprend
mieux ce que vous dites oui et quand je
dis ça c'est pas de l'agressivité
vis-à-vis de manuel valls est une
réflexion que j'ai et un débat que je
peux avoir avec lui parce que comment
elle peut avoir une légitimité cette loi
il ya plusieurs méthodes ça aurait pu
être dans notre programme devant les
électeurs en 2012 c'est pas le cas on
avait promis l'un vertes sera pu être un
accord entre le patronat français et la
majorité des accords des syndicats comme
ça a été le cas en 2013 moi même j'étais
rapporteur d'un texte comme safin et
justement il faut y avoir des chances de
dialogue et il y aurait pu avoir le
soutien public si ce qui n'est pas le
cas donc mais vous avez raison de dire
que c'est pas fini
c'est pour ça que moi je fais la
proposition l'agonie son parcours
retrouvons nous autour de la table mais
pas deux heures avant le prochain 49 3
dès cette semaine
et moi j'ai fait des propositions parce
que si on avait été en dix ans cette loi
n'en veut pas c'est tout ou rien le
comprendre et à la limite le premier
ministe disant moi il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui sont bonnes pour le
pays et je veux les faire avancer
mais on n'est pas dans cette situation
on a fait des propositions très
concrètes
trois ou quatre amendements qui sont pas
des détails bien sûr qu'ils sont des
choses importantes
voilà qui consiste vous savez le premier
ministre il veut favoriser la
négociation d'entreprise nous ont dit ok
mais il faut l'encadrer par deux choses
le principe de first air que ces accords
doivent être plus favorable que les
accords de man show que les règles
de la loi et puis deuxième élément que
les branches professionnelles qui
régissent les règles dans un secteur
d'activité définissent dans quel cadre
ça ça fait longtemps que jamais lancé
cet appel ça date pas d'hier
vous avez reçu une réponse ou pas d'un
mot et apprenant le parent a reçu de
réponse négative si ce n'est le 49-3
bien sûr ça c'est une forme de réponse à
venir qui n'a pas vraiment envie de
discuter
oui mais la porte reste ouverte et
passent du temps pour aboutir parce que
si à la nouvelle lecture qui sera la
dernière
il n'ya pas 289 plus un député c'est toi
ne sera jamais la queue c'est pourquoi
c'est vraiment par le peloton passera
une majorité socialiste pour voter ce
texte en deuxième lecture à la fois
aujourd'hui non mais mais si on va dans
le sens que nous proposons qui rejoint
d'ailleurs celui que propose un certain
nombre de députés que vous appelez
d'ailleurs frondeurs loyalistes enfin
c'est un peu bizarre de parler de ça
c'est le mot les mots qui sont dans
l'opinion publique
mais les frondeurs il se considère comme
loyalistes parce qu'ils font ce qu'on
avait promis aux électeurs et les autres
ont supporté voilà enfin repasser à la
suite du feuilleton ce mercredi la
gauche légèrement éparpillés justement
alors peut-on vraiment parler de cassure
on va voir toutes les explications avec
ce reportage signé françois chevret ce
mercredi 16h35 et pas de motion de
censure de gauche déposés sur le bureau
du président de l'assemblée nationale
c'est invraisemblable on mesure
déposé sept décès de censure
- nous avons pris 50 sociétés le matin
les frondeurs se réunissaient à huis
clos pour se mettre d'accord
non ils ne voteront pas la motion de la
droite déposé la veille
oui ils veulent constituer leur propre
motion il leur reste alors quelques
heures pour rassembler 58 signature
c'est dur parce que les délais ne
permettent pas forcément de rassembler
tout de suite autant de personnes que
l'on voudrait peut-être que le don de
mon train mais ce qui compte c'est leur
origine démarche politique on va essayer
rapidement le groupe des communistes et
front de gauche signe ainsi que la
gauche des écologistes à 15 heures
pendant les questions au gouvernement
les frondeurs font des pieds et des
mains pour trouver de nouveaux
signataires dans les rangs socialistes
16h15 l'écologiste noël mamère donne
l'état des avancées il nous manque très
peu de voix sa seconde de moins que les
doigts d'une main
à moins de cinq minutes de l'heure
fatidique
l'espoir fait place à l'évidence seuls
56 députés apportent leur soutien à la
motion de censure
il en manque donc de mai les signataires
refusent de parler d'échec
lorsque c'est pas rien d avoir essayé de
déposer cette motion de censure on n'a
pas voulu voter la motion de censure de
la droite parce qu'on n'a pas voulu être
dans une forme d'incohérence politique
sur le fond mais on a essayé de réunir
des hommes et les femmes de gauche des
parlementaires des députés je raisonne
en termes de devoir nous a semblé
nécessaire de faire ça nous a semblé que
c'était notre devoir montbard on l'a
fait près d'une trentaine de députés
socialistes ont signé la motion une
division comme le groupe ps n'en avait
jamais connu
donc la motion de censure a été discutée
jeudi on en reparlera dans un instant
essayant de les lever un tout petit peu
il ya deux gauches irréconciliables a
dit manuel valls pour vous aussi à deux
gauches irréconciliables aujourd'hui non
pas du tout et je pense même que si on
n'arrive pas à réconcilier les deux
gauches
oui on a même plus d'ailleurs une gauche
communiste une gauche sociale démocrate
une gauche socialiste ya les écologistes
aussi qu'il faut que leur part dû
gratter la zone liste moi je parle de la
gauche en général parce que bon - parti
socialiste et la gauche csss ça n'a pas
de sens de les distinguer je dis que si
on n'arrive pas à réconcilier ces
gauches
nous ne reviendrons jamais au pouvoir
moi je cherche pas le pouvoir pour le
pouvoir
nommé mais pour rejoindre qui nous font
qu'ils nous font confiance
oui nous y sommes mais vous voyez bien
qu'on arrive même plus enfin le premier
ministre n'avait plus à gouverner avec
une majorité puisque
gomery déchéance de nationalité
non mais vous savez le premier ministre
ils l'ont mais il n'ya plus de majorité
jean marc gens sur ces textes ya pas une
majorité c'est une évidence il n'aura
gardé manuel gouverner bien sur
l'institutionnel et que la constitution
le lui permet mais ce que je veux dire
c'est que le premier ministre ait encore
une fois comme tu dis ça je pense qu'ils
aient besoin de respect dans la vie
publique et c'est de construire une
autre majorité il le revendique il a
essayé de trouver des voix au centre et
y compris en écoutant les parlementaires
du centre qui a lui ont fait des
propositions mais au moment du vote ils
n'ont jamais été là il a aussi écouté le
patronat qui demandaient des aides
il les a accordées qui demandaient les
souplesses il les a accordées et vous
voyez qu au moment d'être au rendez vous
de soutenir un texte qu'il dépose le
patronat le lâche plus il faut écouter
la gauche jeudi à manuel valls que la
tentative
on peut la partager ou pas mais elle a
échoué de recomposer la majorité
différemment donc je lui dis comme je
lui avais dit aux premiers jours de son
mandat de premier ministre de ses
fonctions de premier ministre il avait
la gentillesse de nous recevoir à
matignon je lui avais dit il faut que tu
sois le patron de la gauche et de
l'écologie un premier ministre peut être
que ça parce que notre majorité
elle est issue de 2012 on peut rêver
d'autre chose pour le prochain avec un
canard mais dans ce quinquennat là il
n'y a pas d'autres majorités que celle
qu'ont voulu les français c'est la
manière dont vous y prenez pour recoller
les morceaux entre ces deux gauches
irréconciliables qu'est-ce que oui et
c'est pour ça je dis c'est pour ça que
je veux dire un mot sur la motion de
censure parce que il ya des gens qui
m'aiment bien dans ma circonscription et
dans le pays qui m'ont dit monsieur le
député jean-marc pourquoi est-ce que tu
n'as pas de signer cette motion comme ça
il aurait pu arriver aux 58 et serait
bloqué la loi ne serait pas bloquer la
loi il fallait qu'ils aient une majorité
de gauche pour pour la bloquer c'est
pour ça que je n'ai pas fait parce que
cette démarche n'avait aucune chance
d'aboutir orale a fait croire un certain
nombre de personnes qu'on avait la
capacité de bloquer non les députés
n'ont pas la capacité de bloquer
cantilien 49,3 tout ça pour rien depuis
1962 jamais aucun aucune motion de
sergent ce que vous avez abouti
donc si donc voilà je ne voulais pas je
voulais pas le faire par ailleurs les
frondeurs avaient eux mêmes la capacité
en leur sein de dépasser les 50 8
puisque en a plusieurs que parmi eux qui
ne l'ont pas signé
et puis deuxième point c'est là où je
veux en venir moi je ne renonce pas à et
je réponds à votre question à
réconcilier à ressouder ses de gauche et
donc je veux je ne veux pas faire des
actes inutiles sur le plan du résultat
moi je veut bloquer la loi et s'il y
avait un moyen de la bloquer je leur ai
fait mais qui par contre créé des
cicatrices profondes c'est ce que
j'appelle la dérive des continents c'est
de gauche qui s'éloigne de plus en plus
le cas jours jusqu'au jour mais c'est
pas encore le cas où elles seront
irréconciliables et où la verte ne
pourra plus revenir aux responsabilités
mais on retient quand même un geste
inutile finalement cette motion sociaux
la motion de censure de gauche et la
motion de censure de droite parce que la
question s'est posée les communistes
l'ont d'ailleurs être une opposition
elle aura abouti à quoi au retour de la
droite et donc quel aura été le premier
acte de la droite
moi je les imagine très bien il aurait
pris la loi de conneries dans sa loge sa
version 0 et ils auront dit à monsieur
valls madame elle comme ris et
parlementaire votée cette loi là et donc
on aura eu la loi elle comme ray empire
donc moi j'ai pas voulu de vendeurs
d'ailleurs mais là non plus oui car
reste-t-il de cette loi travail jean
marc germain de quel texte parle-t-on
exactement depuis que le gouvernement a
décidé d'utiliser le 49-3 sur ce texte
vous propose cet éclairage de rim
benameur voici le texte qui sera adoptée
après le 49-3
c'est la version sortie de commission
des affaires sociales sauf sur trois
mesures très importantes
le gouvernement a cédé sur un point
les licenciements économiques à
l'origine il souhaitait que ce soient
les résultats en france qu'ils soient
prises en compte pour justifier les
licenciements économiques
finalement ce sera le périmètre
international comme le voulait le
rapporteur et les députés de gauche
en revanche le gouvernement ira jusqu'au
bout sur l'autre point explosif les
accords d'entreprise un accord
d'entreprise pour a primé sur un accord
de branche
il y a donc bien une inversion de la
hiérarchie des normes très décriée par
les syndicats et la gauche
chaque année les branches dresseront un
bilan de ces accords le gouvernement a
fait un geste en direction du medef sur
la surtaxation des cdd il abandonne
cette idée censé limiter les embauches
précaire en tout le gouvernement
retiendra 469 amendements sur les 5000
déposés sur le projet de loi travail
alors vous dites que la porte est encore
ouverte pour éviter un nouveau 49,31
lecture à l'assemblée
sur quoi précisément vous avez dit tout
à l'heure que le premier il pouvait
faire un geste sur quoi doit-il faire un
geste par exemple sur cet article 2 très
contesté qui inverse la hiérarchie des
normes
oui je crois que c'est le plus important
si on devait hiérarchiser chez parlant
dirar si d'énormes pourquoi pourquoi
c'est dangereux cet article parce que
vous allez avoir une concurrence un
dumping social qui va se mettre en place
entre les entreprises je vous donne
juste un exemple imaginons que un
constructeur automobile qui pourra le
faire si cette loi est votée au bout du
bout décide de dire les heures sup chez
nous c'est pas
25 c'est 10 et l'autre constructeur et
bat s'aligner au final vous avez quoi
deux entreprises qui se retrouvent au
même niveau et les salariés qui se
retrouvent lésés sans parler du fait que
les mêmes entreprises vont dire à tous
leurs sous traitants
écoutez maintenant si vous voulez rester
référencé chez nous vous devez passer à
10% aujourd'hui vous avez un accord de
la métallurgie qui a été signé entre les
représentants de la métallurgie et leur
syndicat qui a dit non nous les 25 on
n'y touche pas c'est la même chose pour
tous mais qu'est ce qui est bien ça il
faut pas que ce soit possible
ou alors il faut que ce soit possible
s'il ya des contre parties très forte
pour laisser le gouvernement est capable
de faire un geste sur cet article 2 que
la maîtrise ou quelles raisons avez vous
dire une chose si je vais vous dire une
chose il ya un an jour pour jour avec le
premier ministre nous avons signé un
texte et l'ensemble de ses ministres et
la ministre du travail où nous avons
écrit noir sur blanc n'ont pas
simplement nous conserverons la
hiérarchie des normes nous rétablirons
la hiérarchie des normes
donc je ne conçois pas que ce qui a un
an nous réunit c'est nous c'est pas
aujourd'hui
en revanche parce qu'il faut bien
avancer moi je peux pas dire je veux
tous mes amendements rien que mes
amendements et sinon par les appels
passent à un compromis sinon je veux pas
moi ce que j'ai dit au premier ministre
que l'on peut partager ensemble l'idée
qu'il faut développer la négociation
collective en france par rapport à la
loi mais des accords d'entreprise qui
adapte les lois générales où les règles
générales aussi agir local mais il faut
les encadrer
alors passé aujourd'hui parce qu'il y
avait cette motion sociaux on va voir un
petit peu ce qui leur est
et donc la motion de censure a été
déposée par la droite et par le son elle
a été votée par les communistes résultat
des courses ring benameur pour
l'adoption 246 la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adopté aucun
socialiste n'a apporté sa voix à la
motion de droite le gouvernement valls
n'est donc pas renverser qui n'avait
aucun doute
et s'il y avait eu des socialistes qui
est voté cette motion de censure le
résultat n'était connue et la droite n'a
pas réussi bien entendu à renverser le
gouvernement mais les débats eux
marqueront les esprits dès le début de
la séance le discours de christian jacob
s'en prend violemment au premier
ministre vous n'avez plus de basse
politique et le peuple français a zappé
françois hollande en toute franchise le
mieux qui puisse se produire pour la
france c'est de mettre fin et vite à
votre aventure qui se terminera je vous
le prédis comme les années mitterrand et
comme les années jospin udi décide aussi
de voter la motion de la droite tout en
critiquant un pays à l'arrêt comme les
communistes qui dénoncent eux le coup de
force du gouvernement
ainsi le gouvernement ne veut pas
débattre de l'un des textes phares de
son quinquennat
l'humiliation le choc dans vos propres
rangs étaient telles que nous avons été
à deux doigts à deux voix près de
pouvoir déposer une motion de censure
réunissant des députés de toutes les
formations de gauche
cet hémicycle une motion de gauche
signée mercredi par de nombreux
frondeurs manuel valls à la tribune les
mettant en garde
je prends cette tentative pour ce
qu'elle est elle est grave même si elle
a échoué mais leurs signataires sont
dans une impasse
mais je vous donne une conviction je ne
laisserai pas détruire la gauche de
gouvernement
la social démocratie française et oui le
temps de la clarification
venu avec le rejet de la motion de
censure le projet de loi est donc
considéré comme adopté en première
lecture
il poursuivra son parcours au sénat à
partir du 13 juin de questions jean marc
jahn la première c'est que les députés
socialistes n'ont pas pris part au vote
de la motion saint pauloise ont eu
l'envié d'en créer une
le parti socialiste a été notamment pris
part à sa haute autorité pour examiner
le cas de ses députés
est-ce qu'ils doivent être sanctionnés a
certainement pas tout fait y défendre je
rappelais cette signature j'ai eu avec
le premier ministre
c'était dans le cadre du congrès de
poitiers c'était et c'était le texte qui
fondent les principes la profession de
foi des socialistes dans les trois ans
qui suivent ce qu'on a je vois mal qu'on
sanctionne des députés qu'on ait voulu
défendre jusqu'au bout
la première était selon vous je pense
que c'est une erreur et puis par
ailleurs au delà de ça respire la
politique c'est de construire des
majorités c'est de rassembler des femmes
et des hommes autour de soi en
l'occurrence ceux des socialistes à une
majorité qui sont qui sont très proches
c'est le rôle dans nos institutions du
premier ministre qu'il ne lancerait pas
de majorité pied par d'autres donc en ce
moment et vous passiez des éléments de
son discours ou le début vous l'avez pas
au passé mais j'aurais pu être d'accord
ou pas d'accord sur le fond mais il
disait je fais cette loi parce qu'elle
est bonne pour le pays qu'il le pense
normal mais alors après il a passé la
deuxième moitié de son discours à
prendre les députés les uns après les
autres et alors cogner dessus ça c'est
pas possible je veux dire c'est ce qui
est consubstantielle à la fonction de
premier ministre
cette construire des majorités donc il
ne construit pas ça dommage au delà il
n'y a pas de majorité
il aurait pu d'ailleurs moi je le ferai
jamais si j'étais premier ministre
construire une autre majorité avec la
droite mais la droite ne veut pas donc
il n'y a pas de majorité sur ce texte et
il manque d'ailleurs bien plus que les
30 ou 40 députés qu'on a évoqué il
manque sans doute une centaine de
parlementaires et donc son travail pour
ça que je suis content le 49-3 avec le
49-3 conduit à des risques à prendre des
mauvaises décisions politiques je retire
le mot de fautes tout à l'heure si vous
l'avez perçu comme désobligeants
vis-à-vis du premier ministre qui sont
pas bons moi j'ai vécu la période lionel
jospin au premier jour de son
quinquennat il a dit je n'utiliserai
jamais l'article 49-3 conséquence de ça
il passait son temps et ses ministres
aussi à discuter avec les parlementaires
alors les français peuvent se dire les
parlementaires cdh et shearer entre
guillemets qui petits blocs tout mais
c'est pas du tout ça la réalité
regardez sur la loi elle conneries même
les frondeurs même les communistes ils
proposent pas tout supprimer
il ya des propositions qui sont faites
dans moi je récuse l'idée pas que dans
le syndicalisme qui est un peu le
pendant il y aurait des conservateurs et
des réformistes
chacun veut faire avancer les choses
mais une conception différente du
programme a évoqué une autre
personnalité de la semaine puisque
pendant sept ans emmanuel macron avance
il prend des points dans les sondages
même s'il dément vouloir se présenter
éventuellement à la présidentielle mais
on ne parle que de lui sandra sarkar des
levées de fonds pour financer une
campagne présidentielle une candidature
en juin
emmanuel macron dément tout mais selon
son entourage rien et à exclure tout
dépendra du contexte
au mois de septembre on verra en
fonction de la décision du chef de
l'état
demain si une opportunité ou pas elle
n'est pas à exclure
vous avez compris aujourd'hui que
emmanuel macron dit lui-même qui sera
loyal à l'égard de la france bien
entendu à l'égard de deux chefs de
l'état aussi mais loyal jusqu'à quand
car ses proches ne le cache pas emmanuel
macron rêve de devenir président et ils
y travaillent
un mouvement politique en marche bien
structuré et des soutiens de plus en
plus nombreux sa liberté c'est
formidable et il ouvre île où la
perspective à ce qui est en jeu c'est
quand même la campagne présidentielle
c'est de quel côté elle va tomber
elle va tomber côté vieux xxème siècle
ou côté jeunes 21e siècle il y a ceux
qui évoquent un pacte avec un ralliement
possible à françois hollande lors du
second tour
seul scénario possible pour les proches
du chef de l'état tout le monde à la
place dans l'équipe à partir du moment
où tout le monde est derrière le chef
d'equipe je suis jean qu'emmanuel macro
aussi en tout cas je veux le croire
françois hollande miserait donc sur son
protégé pour récupérer des voix le
moment venu une stratégie électorale à
double tranchant est-ce que la position
actuelle des manuels macro qui aimait
lice mais qui parle même temps ailleurs
hors de nos frontières chercher quelques
soutiens est tenable
vous s'expliquer sur ces faits là il a
été interpellé par un parlementaire de
droite à ce sujet mais moi ce que je
voulais dire c'est que pour moi
politique ça rime avec éthique et quand
on est ministre on doit être à 100% à sa
tâche si on veut être candidat et
personne ne peut lui dénier la
légitimité à présenter sa candidature
il faut en tirer les conséquences et
partir pour qui un autre ministre qui
puisse être à 100% à redresser chômage
voilà donc soit il met en sommeil sur sa
formation politique et s'est levé de son
il revient à 100% à bercy ne soit ils en
tirent les conséquences mais encore une
fois c'est une décision personnelle
moi je suis jamais à demander la
démission d'un ministre mais est ce que
par exemple pour les repas dans votre
voix les mots de martine aubry
macron commandes hier album écoutez
quand elle s'est exprimée à ce sujet là
elle s'exprimer sur des sujets bien
précis ça concernait le travail ça
concerne l économie et ça visait les
politiques qu'ils qu'il même là on est
sur autre chose là on est sur la
question est ce qu'on peut préparer une
candidature à la présidentielle et être
en même temps ministre
ma réponse est non donc il faut qu'il
choisisse un bref pas qu'il pourrait
selon vous avoir la carrure d'un
président je ne me suis pas du tout
prononcer là dessus je dis juste qu'il
peut être mais là qu'ils avouent la
pause
voilà un mois non j'ai pas ces jeux
c'est pour moi la modernité en politique
c'est elle n'est pas représentée par
emmanuel macron alors si vous me disiez
qui je serai très gêné par le faire mais
je vais vous le dire quand même mais
français savent que je suppose d'elle
mais c'est plutôt anne hidalgo et ce
qu'elle fait la mairie de paris et son
éthique aussi parce qu'elle elle dit moi
je suis maire de paris
les parisiens - élu pour être maire de
paris et donc je serai pas candidate à
la présidentielle de 2017
la prochaine c'est la modernité en pays
et elles travaillent avec le nouveau
maire de londres et elle va
travailler avec les maires des plus
grandes villes pour essayer de faire
avancer nos idées pour essayer de faire
mal go coûte et ça c'est pas son porte
parole mais je voulais juste à
l'éclairer je voulais juste éclairé à
travers sable pour moi ce qu'est la
vraie modernité en politique on va
passer à la loupe du scan
aujourd'hui mme bonjour jean marc
germain on vient parler de d'emmanuel
emmanuel macron justement regardez cette
scène qui s'est déroulée mardi c'était
pendant les questions au gouvernement à
l'assemblée le premier ministre a été
obligé de démentir que sont mises
l'économie a cherché à lever des fonds
on vient d'en parler en vue d'une
éventuelle candidature
s'en est suivie une explication vraiment
houleuse sur les bancs des ministres
entre les deux hommes concrètement est
ce qu'ils peuvent encore coexister
manuel valls emmanuel macron on semble
d'une même équipe gouvernementale est ce
que c'est possible
en tout cas si j'ai bien compris la
teneur de la conversation je crois que
le premier ministre ait raison de
recadrer son ministre en lui disant tu
dois être à ta tâche tu dois être au
travail et si tu veut autre chose dit le
donc moi je soutiens totalement le
premier ministre et est dans son rôle
à ce moment là après est-ce que ça peut
dire ou pas mais c'est emmanuel macron
de le dire en fonction d'eux
du débat convient d'avoir sur est ce que
il est vraiment candidat est ce qu'il a
besoin de temps pour qu'on sera créée
pour préparer sa candidature et si c'est
le cas il doit en tirer les conséquences
par rapport à son procès manuel valls a
eu raison d'eux bien sûr et encore une
fois mais celle ci il est tout à fait
dans son rôle
vraiment c'est l'autorité c'est
important aussi
à condition qu'elle soit utilisée à bon
escient donc l'autorité par rapport à un
ministre en lui demandant d'être apte sa
tâche c'est à bon escient par exemple 49
3 parlons maintenant un peu de françois
hollande
après paris et au la gauche vous savez
c'est ce fameux rassemblement des
ministres en soutien au bilan de
françois hollande
il devait organiser une réunion mardi
prochain à lille qui est la ville de
martine aubry finalement on a appris que
c'était fade le foll a annoncé que le
rassemblement ne naît pas avoir lieu
est-ce qu'il faut y voir une
contrepartie au fait que les aubry ce
n'est n'est pas voter la motion de
censure de la gauche contre le
gouvernement écoutez pas avoir de
contrepartie parce que c'est pas un
cadeau ne pas avoir noté laisser
simplement nous avions réfléchi par
rapport à notre éthique tu vous ai dit
si j'avais pensé que ça avait pu arrêter
cette loge je leur ai voté je pense que
martin un brave murray a prouvé en ce
sens en revanche je trouve que c'est une
bonne décision
d'abord cette affaire et au la gauche
franchement c'est pas compris par les
français c'est pas aux ministres se tord
ministres d'être sur des tribunes
stéphane le foll c'est un peu différent
il anime un courant politique des amis
de françois hollande il peut le faire
mais qu'on ait des brochette de
ministres
à ce moment là vous allez les français
ils n'attendent qu'une chose en ce
moment de nous ministres ou
parlementaires c'est qu'on soit la tâche
pour essayer de répondre aux problèmes
du pays pour essayer d'être fidèle
autant que possible on à l'europe
s'éloigner un peu de nos engagements et
je trouve que c'est vraiment pas le
moment
surtout que ça inverse un peu les choses
c'est plutôt la gauche qui dit hey ho le
gouvernement et donc et au les
parlementaires aussi vous avez vu qu'on
n'est pas tous d'accord
je crois qu'il faut prendre ça comme une
interpellation à notre égard active elle
a un objectif c'est crédibiliser la
candidature de françois hollande en 2017
est ce que vous pensez que cette
candidature est légitime
je dirai la même chose que pour emmanuel
macron peut-être encore plus s'agissant
d'un président sortant parfaitement
légitime a présenté la colle sa
candidature mme en revanche ce que je
souhaite moi c'est que notre candidat
puisque vous voyez il ya des noms qui
circulent on a parlé aujourd'hui en a
d'autres qui vont peut-être s'exprimer
au mont beuvray
par exemple moi j'ai mes propres
préférences mais je vous en parlerai pas
d'en parler sur toi pourquoi je vous dis
ça c'est que y'a qu'une comme je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure il n'y a qu'une seule
méthode pour trancher des désaccords
politiques au sens noble du terme on a
des différences de vue sur la loi elle
conneries il ya que le vote requis pour
mettre trop chez ca en démocrate la
primeur et bien sûr notre candidat il ya
que le vote qui permettra de dire quel
est le meilleur candidat est ce que
c'est froid insolent blé manuelle malot
arnaud montebourg benoît hamon et puis
c'est s'il ya des primaires il y en aura
autant qu'à droite un des candidats
parce que des gens de valeur il y en a
qui sont pas très connu mais il y en a
autant que à droite donc la primaire dit
à l'adulte on m'enlève cette prime un la
primaire de la primaire si possible avec
les verts et les communistes
3 si les verts les communistes disent
non la primaire comme en 2011 c'est à
dire avec une pluralité des candidatures
et un accès relativement facile à la
candidature avec des débats qui auront
lieu et avec un choix qui est fait par
toutes les femmes et les hommes d'arno
vous voulez vous venez parler d'eux
de d'arnaud montebourg et du mont
beuvray en effet il sera lundi c'est sa
traditionnelle ascension son rendez vous
politique qui pourrait annoncer ses
ambitions en vue de 2017
l'épisode de cette semaine sur le 49-3
c'est une formidable rampe de lancement
pour lui finalement est ce qui peut
profiter cet épisode je sais pas mais
moi je vais vous dire la question d'une
candidature la fronde
christian paul par exemple oui ils ont
des proximités avec arnaud montebourg
mais moi je vais vous dire la question
des candidatures à ce stade elle ne
m'intéresse pas du tout parce que je
pense qu'on a à faire autre chose c'est
ce dont on parlait tout à l'heure
rck août c'est gauche se mettre autour
d'une table pour voir si on est capable
d'avoir un projet ensemble pour la
france et quand je parle des gauches
parler gauche politique
les communistes les écologistes les
socialistes et différentes tendances du
socialisme mais je parle aussi des
gauche citoyenne et de la gauche
politique parce que vous savez ces
mouvements type nuit debout ou l
initiative contre la loi travail et la
vigilance à l'égard des parlementaires
qu'à monter caroline de haas et commenté
caroline de haas et se fit binet c'est
des éléments très importants de la
politique de célébration que ces
fictions martine aubry pour les
prochains mois voilà et donc on a en a
expliqué hier qu'on allait cet été
proposé aux uns et aux autres de se
retrouver dans ce qu'on appelle un
carrefour de la gaude et gauchy venez de
l'écologie comment ça va se passer
non on peut pas en dire plus à ce stade
parce qu'on en parlera quand ce sera
fait mais en tout cas notre volonté
c'est de contribuer à cette
reconstruction future des gauches
merci jean mach germa et à très bientôt
ça me suffit de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires